Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the brand new rollback format
of the Rich Roll Podcast,
where we share the best episodes from our audio only catalog
with all of you guys.
Currently, almost 300 incredible evergreen conversations
are nowhere to be found on YouTube.
And so to begin to remedy this misfortune,
we bring you episode number 63,
all the way back from January of 2014,
with the infinitely inspiring Josh LaJaunie.
This episode actually began with a tweet
way back in the day.
Josh reached out to me cold
sending me these before and after pictures
of his dramatic weight loss
to kind of thank me for inspiring him.
And I just found these images,
and the change that he had experienced so astounding
that my first thought was, can this even be real?
This 400 plus pound guy on the left,
bore almost zero resemblance to the guy on the right.
It was frankly stunning because Chris Farley
had suddenly morphed into something like Bradley Cooper.
Truly a manifesto on life transformation,
this episode represents the detailed personal account
of how Josh accomplished what many would deem impossible,
dropping over 200 pounds,
along with his lifelong addiction to unhealthy foods,
and lifestyle habits,
to ultimately discover a passion for running,
and, of course, plant-based eating.
And it's a feat that's even more impressive
considering that Josh
lives deep in the heart of Southern Louisiana Bayou Country,
which is a place not exactly known for healthy eating,
and having to risk
complete social outcast status in doing so.
So how did Josh do it?
Well, you're gonna have to listen to find out.
So here is Josh LaJaunie,
in one of the most inspiring and heartwarming episodes,
in the history of this podcast, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
Thank you for rolling.
All right.
So thanks for taking the time, man.
No, thank you.
This is really, actually, quite an honor for me.
Well, it's an honor for me I got to tell you.
I was trying to remember how it went down,
but I think what happened is you tweeted
that before and after picture.
Right.
And, like, tagged me in it, and I saw it.
And I was like, holy smokes.
Yeah.
People send me before and after pictures
all the time.
Right.
But yours was definitely,
like, maybe the most dramatic,
not just because of the simple weight loss,
but because the after picture,
you didn't just look like a guy who lost a lot of weight.
You were like a guy who was,
like, super fit all of a sudden.
Which has been my goal, right?
Which has been my goal,
and it hasn't been all of a sudden, obviously,
but, yes, absolutely, and turning to plants
has really sort of that's how that transformation happened
because I stopped caring about weight ironically enough,
and started caring about optimal health and fitness.
And it really became my biggest goal and driver,
and discovering plants and people like you,
and Brendan Brazier, and Scott Jurek along the way,
Scott McDougall, reading "Born to Run."
Those things literally without hyperbole or being dramatic
literally changed my life, man.
Well, it's so cool to see you,
like, killing it right now.
And I think that's a really important point.
And I was, like, reading the document that you sent me,
which we're gonna get into all that,
and we're gonna into your story, and all that kind of stuff,
but the thing that jumped out at me the most in your story
was that point where you had already lost
quite a bit of weight,
but you had kind of started to stagnate a little bit,
and I think you started to even out,
and you still had a long way to go,
and you made this decision
that it wasn't gonna be about weight loss.
It wasn't gonna be about what the number on the scale said.
You were just gonna focus on getting fit,
and let go of the rest of that.
And that's kind of when it all shifted for you,
and you had this,
you sort of broke the glass ceiling on the whole thing.
Absolutely, 'cause I've lost nearly 100 pounds
more than once in my life, I have done that before.
Right immediately after my college football,
short-lived college football career ended,
I did drop nearly 90 pounds after that,
but it was just for pure aesthetics,
and for the sake of losing weight and looking better.
It never really cracked for me
to be healthy.
That's what running and plants in this whole epiphany
has really brought about to me.
And they helped me turn that corner.
And I think probably being older,
and a little bit more mature
has helped with that process also.
Right, so how old are you now?
I'm 35.
35, all right.
So let's take it back to the beginning,
so, yeah, 'cause your story is pretty cool.
I mean, people say to me all the time,
like, who inspires you?
Like, who are the people that really motivate you?
And, honestly, man, it's not like some professional athlete
that did this or that, it's guys like you,
you know, the everyday dude,
who no one's really looking at them.
They're not in the public eye, or anything like that.
And they just make this decision,
and turn their lives around in such a huge way.
People are always saying to me,
you gotta have some average people on,
have some normal dudes on the show,
and let them tell their story, you know?
And you are, like, you just leapt off the page
as one of these guys, so let's see.
So you have this sort of ill-fated stab at college, right?
Like what happened, man?
Well, I probably honestly thought
I was a little better than I was.
I did get a full ride scholarship,
and I was so proud of that fact,
and I just sorta almost kinda rode the wave on that alone.
So hold on.
So you grew up in the New Orleans area.
Correct.
I grew up in a small town called Thibodaux,
which it's on the Bayou.
I live in I'm, like, part of, I guess,
the country knows about "Swamp People,"
and all of the different deal.
With our new Hollywood South sort of identity down here,
a lot more people with all of the film trucks and crews,
a lot more people know about who we are now
as far as characters anyway.
So you're like down there,
like it's Creole country pretty much.
Oh, man, yeah, no, we're coon-asses, bro.
Creole is a little fancier than what we are.
We are pure Cajuns, grew up fishing and hunting,
and making, like I say,
making roux and stews with anything that moves,
that's what we grew up doing, man.
Uh-huh, nice.
And so you're playing football in high school?
Yes, absolutely, I sure did.
I played ball in high school, and in high school I was about
6'3", 280-ish, 290-ish,
and it got a little bit bigger every year.
I got some looks in college in my senior year.
The one college that was really interested in me
was willing to give me a full scholarship.
They wanted me to switch over to the offensive line,
which I had played defensive line
throughout my whole high school career.
And so I was like,
I really wasn't pumped about playing O-line,
but it was an opportunity for me,
and they told me to put on some weight.
They wanted me to put on some weight.
So I get up there and I'm 330 now.
I get up there and I go through my training camp.
So you were 330,
and they wanted you to put more weight on?
No, no, no, at the end of my senior year,
I was closer to about 300.
What did you weigh in high school?
In high school I flipped, I went from about 280,
my sophomore year up to about 295 my senior year.
Holy smokes.
So were you just a big kid,
or, like, how did you put so much weight on?
How tall are you?
It's just natural, I'm 6'4" now.
I was 6'2", 6'3" in that area in high school, yeah.
Uh-huh, were you one of those kids
who was just always the biggest, strongest kid in the class?
Right, yeah, I was always the big kid,
and my grandfather was a big man.
I come from big people, and my grandmother kept us heavy.
What was it like when you were growing up?
Like, what was the typical meal in the house,
or what was a day in the life of food for you?
Oh, my goodness.
Well, my grandfather owned a construction business,
and I spent a lot of time spending a night with them,
and getting up to go to work in the morning.
Now, what we would do before anybody ever got up,
what woke us up was the smell of bacon in the morning,
and my grandmother cooking biscuits.
And so we had bacon, biscuits, and gravy,
the standard scrambled eggs.
She did these awesome fig preserves.
She made all of these different things.
And so every meal in the house throughout the day
was a completely one-off meal,
brand new, fresh cooked, hot meal, breakfast.
We came home for lunch and it was a hot meal for lunch.
And the same thing for supper.
And we had snacks all in between.
It was all about food,
and the food was the love in their mind.
They come from more meager beginnings.
And I feel like a lot of their agrarian, like, background,
and the Depression,
Arab folks,
I feel like they really kind of overcompensate with food
because they had so little back then,
and they want to make sure
that the people they're taking care of
really understand how much they love them via food.
Right.
I feel like that happens a lot, you know?
Right, right.
Do you have brothers and sisters?
Yeah, I sure do.
Uh-huh, so how many of those?
I have a younger brother
who is about 2-1/2 years younger than I am.
Also was a football player, also a big man.
By the way, he to date is down almost 150 pounds.
Wow.
Since he's followed me along
'cause when I first brought it up as an idea,
he's like, "Dude, really?
You're gonna give up meat, and crawfish.
and you're gonna give up fish?"
And, I mean, it just blew his mind, you know?
Uh-huh.
I said, give me 30 days and watch me.
Just give me 30 days.
And we did it that way and it worked out.
And so my little sister same boat.
My little sister is about five years younger
than my little brother,
so about 7-1/2 years younger than me.
She's a lot shorter than we are.
We're both big stature fellows,
like, we take after my grandfather,
who's the patriarch of our family.
And he was 6'3" in the high 300s my whole life.
We called him Bamm-Bamm.
And he was 380, 360, 380 my whole life.
Wow.
My little sister she's got really heavy, too.
So that's it, that's all of us as far as the siblings go.
It's just the three of us.
Me and my brother, and my sister,
and I have two little cousins as well.
The youngest of those two little cousins, first cousins,
he's like 6'3",
he's like 6'3", 290.
Uh-huh.
He's a senior in high school right now.
Man, you're a big family.
Yeah, we are.
That's like a reality show right there, right?
All right, so you go to college.
They're putting you on the offensive line, you beef up.
You beef up to about what, 330, I think you said?
Yeah, 330.
Uh-huh, and so what happens, man?
What happens in college then?
It sucked.
(laughing)
You weren't having a good time.
I was not having a good time.
It was a completely different mindset
playing on that side of the ball.
It wasn't what was in my heart.
I was heavier than I had ever been,
working harder against better players
than I had ever played against.
And it just wasn't, I wasn't feeling it.
And then lo and behold, I get hurt.
My back starts bothering me really bad
to the point to where I got a bulging disk,
and all of these other issues going on,
that I could have probably in retrospect,
maybe rehabbed through and pushed through,
and sat out a season and corrected myself,
but I hung it up instead, and came back home
after that little stab.
Right, so not only was football done,
you were done with school, too.
I mean, you just weren't happy.
You weren't happy in the school itself
outside off the field.
Right, I was not happy,
and really because where I had gone,
'cause I'm from South Louisiana,
and I had gone up to rural Arkansas.
The campus was in a dry county,
and that was a big deal for me.
I mean, I'm a college kid.
Yeah, that's no good for college.
No, man.
How are you supposed to, wow.
And so what I do once football is over for me,
and I decide to come on back to Thibodaux,
and I get back here and I go back to Nicholls,
and then kind of just go off the deep end.
When I try to go back to just school and no football at all,
I kind of go off the deep end, and have a real good time
with all the people that I missed.
And then I flunk out, essentially, I just flunk out.
You were just having too much of a good time.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you're making up for the fact
that you're not an athlete anymore,
and you can just let it all hang out.
That's exactly right.
Right, and that was at Nicholls State?
Yeah.
So is that the one in Arkansas,
or you transferred to a different school?
I transferred back home.
I got you, Nicholls State is in Thibodaux?
Thibodaux.
I got you, all right, cool.
That's right.
Yeah, so you just partied yourself
right out of school.
Sure did.
You did.
All right, man.
Yeah, I know what that's like.
Yeah.
That's what I think resonated with me so much, man.
And being an older guy when I first started trying,
you're the one that made me go,
hey, it doesn't matter how old I am.
I can start attacking these runs.
Like, running is almost like my second chance
at proving my athletic prowess, you know?
Yeah, man, I mean, you definitely embody that.
So, I mean, do you hit a bottom with all this stuff?
I mean, after you drop out of college, what are you doing?
Are you working with your dad, or something like that,
or what's happening?
No, well, not quite yet.
I'm just kind of floating around taking odd salesmen jobs.
I bartended a little while,
and did those types of normal things.
And then I wound up working with my grandfather eventually.
Doing construction.
Doing that, right, doing construction,
and he's got rental property and stuff.
And so I started doing that.
And my grandmother passed away in '01.
And so I had to take more of a leadership role
in that whole,
that whole front.
With the business, or with your family?
With the business, right.
With the business and with the family,
and helping him in a more real way.
It sounds like your family is pretty tight.
Yeah, very, very tight.
Right.
All right, so you're stepping it up on the business front,
so you're sort of moving up in that world, right?
Like things are going along all right?
Right, moving, that's right.
And having a little bit of a purpose, right?
Uh-huh, so where did the wheels
really start to fall off the wagon here?
As far as food goes,
the wheels were always off the wagon.
That was the MO for my family,
and really for the entire region,
the wheels are kinda off the wagon.
They're permanently off.
Right, right.
The truck is just up on cinder blocks all the time.
Yeah.
I mean, we're in love with a lot of bad things
that we actually identify with.
It's more than just food it's actually who we think we are.
It's actually our culture,
and there's so much more to it than that.
That's my biggest reason for reaching out,
and trying to be voices to show the people that
I call my buddy brethren they still don't really get it.
And don't know that I almost feel like I've turned my back,
or I feel like other people might feel like
I've turned my back on a big part of our culture
because I don't partake in some of the
food, or most of the food.
Yeah, I mean, I think that adds
a really interesting sort of dimension,
and complexity to your story,
because not only do you have this sort of
personal war you have to wage to get fit,
and lose all this weight,
you have to butt up against all of these cultural mores,
and ideas about, you know, what it means to be a man,
and the way you have to eat,
and the kind of things you have to do.
And you're taking a different attack,
and going in the other direction, and that causes a lot of,
I would imagine, like, social problems for you.
Oh, goodness, man.
And that's what I tell people all the time.
The food isn't really as hard as ignoring noise,
it really is.
The noise is a bigger thing than anything.
Oh, you're not gonna have a drink?
Like, I mean, I've done enough.
I've had enough to last a normal human their entire life,
as far as bad food, and alcohol goes.
I'm good right now, you know?
And getting that across to folks down here
I feel like an alien sometimes,
but it needs to happen, you know?
It needs to happen for a lot of us.
Right, I mean, I live in L.A.,
and essentially we're all pussies here, you know?
(laughing)
I mean, if there's one place, I mean,
you could eat the way that you eat,
or I eat here that's just the way it is,
it's, like, that's the way most people,
not everybody, but nobody's gonna give you a hard time.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Like it's very welcoming and opening.
So I haven't had to kind of combat the kind of issues
that you've got to come up against, I mean.
I want to get into all of that in more detail,
but just getting back into the kind of timeline narrative.
So you're just progressively putting on weight every year,
I assume, and the quality of your life is sort of,
I mean, you're doing okay with the job,
and all that kind of stuff,
but your health is progressively starting to deteriorate.
Right, I'm just getting heavier and heavier.
Along the way I meet my wife and marry my wife,
and get even more comfortable.
She convinces me, actually, to go back to school,
which I didn't understand why I needed to go back to school.
And I did, and during that process,
I started to learn to learn really,
for lack of a better way of putting it
in a way that I had never understood before.
And I understood how to seek facts and find facts.
And as I became, as I got a little bit of an education
outside of just working with my hands,
I started to understand
that there's some things wrong here, man.
It's not okay to not fit in a desk, dude.
And it's not okay to break a sweat
walking from class to class, I mean.
And all of these things
that I started to get really sort of embarrassed about
I really felt a real want and need to change.
I felt like I was now becoming more equipped to go,
okay, let's start doing something.
I was really embarrassed about doing presentations.
And I put that in that little thing that I wrote to you.
Right.
I didn't want to have to stand in front of people
with my shirt tucked in, and that was a big deal, so,
but I would just worry just sort of aimlessly.
And one of my lifelong buddies
just calls me out of the blue one day
that's how one of these things, how the universe works
just as I'm worrying and thinking my phone rings,
and it's my partner, and he says,
"Hey, dude, I got to join a gym, man."
And we just have that conversation, you know?
Right.
So it's funny that it coincides with this decision
to kind of go back to school.
I mean, that comes from a place of on some level,
a desire for greater self-esteem,
and then kind of going to school,
and developing that self-esteem
not having to be the guy who dropped out of college,
and actually kind of taking care of business.
Right.
And at the same time to kind of depleting,
devolving self-esteem
that comes with getting progressively heavier and heavier,
and all of that.
That's right.
And those two worlds become incompatible
with each other after a little bit, right?
Right.
So, yeah, I often think like,
life can boil down to these tiny little moments,
these little sort of occurrences that could mean nothing,
or could mean everything, you know,
and so you get this phone call from your buddy,
right at the exact time when you're starting to get ready
to do something about this.
And for me, I had a similar kind of thing.
It wasn't as dramatic as your event,
but when that little opportunity meets that willingness,
crazy amazing things can happen.
Yeah, it did, I mean,
and I tell him to this day,
he's a grown-ass man with his own family,
and I tell him to this day that I love him.
Like, I love him for that.
And it wasn't because he saw his buddy getting fat.
He was worried about him, you know?
And he wanted me to come with him.
Right.
That's as simple as it was, you know?
Right, so you're helping him and he's helping you.
Yeah.
The best way to put it.
And that's the best, a win-win.
I mean, how do you get better than that?
Yeah, because you have accountability to your buddy
because you know he's gonna show up at the gym at five,
and if you're not there he's gonna be pissed.
Right.
And you guys can keep each other on track.
And we go rag each other.
We're going, man, what's up?
You couldn't get up this morning?
Ha-ha, okay, what you got some pink drawers on today?
You know what I'm talking about?
I mean, we could get on each other about it, that's it.
Right, right, and at this time,
you didn't even know how much you weighed, right?
Like, you were just off the scale,
like literally off the scale.
The scale wouldn't go as high as you were.
No, man, it wouldn't.
My wife has a little scale that I would get on,
and I had been getting on it for a couple of years
where it just had little E's across it.
That's all it would say, E, it had, like, four E's.
And I guess that signifies error.
Right.
And that was it.
And even when I would go to my doctor's office
on the tall, regular normal doctor scale,
it only went to 350.
So the lady, when I would go in,
the lady would slide the little weight
all the way to the right, which was 350.
And I would step on it and go clunk.
And it wasn't even close to registering anything, you know?
What was your doctor telling you
when you would go in for your checkup, or whatever?
Not a whole lot, not anything about my weight.
Really?
Nothing, because it's so normal down here, man.
Wow.
It's so normal down here.
Uh-huh.
And to be frank, my doctor is a friend of mine.
And so I think you kind of would feel,
you have some reservations there,
even if somebody does need
to do something with their weight.
I think there might have been
a little bit of reservation there
to not hurt someone's feelings maybe.
Right.
Or embarrass them
'cause he just would deal with the task at hand,
if I went in there 'cause I rolled an ankle,
or went in there 'cause I was feeling sick,
and he would give me a cortisone shot,
or whatever I was there for that's what we dealt with.
We didn't deal with me being big
'cause so many people have that problem here.
I mean, that's all they would be doing all day every day.
Yeah, well, maybe that's what he should be doing.
I know, absolutely.
What does he say now when you go in?
He is blown away.
Uh-huh.
Completely blown away.
He has to be.
He is, he is.
'Cause I actually did is a funny little side story.
Not funny, it's just a little side story.
The last time I went to him,
I was feeling lightheaded a little bit.
I would get up when I would stand up quickly,
I would get a little lightheaded.
So I went in to see him and he was like,
"Holy cow, man, what have you been doing?"
And I told him about plants, and I told him about running,
and everybody makes little faces when you say, uh, you know?
So, anyway, so he puts me on the heart monitor thing,
and then he winds up sending me to a cardiologist
to make sure that everything's okay.
The cardiologist puts me through a stress test,
and does all kinds of stuff.
And the cardiologist he's like, "Well, dude,"
because at the time I had lost 175 or 180 pounds.
He's like, well, dude, that's why
you're getting lightheaded.
You have all this extra vasculature,
all these extra veins that's been going to
all of this far-reaches of your enormous body
that it's not doing anymore,
and your heart just can't get blood
to all of the far-reaches of those veins
as quickly as you can move now.
And I was like, oh, okay, well, that all makes sense,
but I knew that I was gonna be training for a marathon.
And so did my doctor and that's why he sent me there.
Everybody needed to make sure
that Josh wasn't gonna hurt himself doing this,
reaching out,
and reaching out so far outside of what had been my box.
Right, right.
So, but back to the scale, I mean,
so your wife went out and bought a scale
that could handle a man like you, right?
Right, yeah.
So, and what what does it top out at?
I mean, where do you top out at your heaviest?
Right, I still don't know exactly
where I've topped out, but this was after.
At 397, okay?
Was my first time that I looked at the scale,
and saw a real number for how much I weighed.
But that's already after you'd been working out,
and kind of started taking control of stuff.
So it's conceivable you weighed more than that
at some point.
Yeah, I think it would be conservative to say
that I was probably more around 410 easily
because I was losing weight when I was so heavy.
I was losing weight at such a rapid pace
because of how heavy I was.
It was easy to lose weight in the beginning.
And so I think it's very conservative to say
that I was 410, 415 pounds to start with.
I mean, when you weigh that much, I mean,
what are the kind of things that people might not realize
that you kind of have to deal with,
you know, whether it's sort of?
Think about it.
Things that would be really fun to most people,
say, like, I'll take my honeymoon for an example.
My wife and I flew,
we went to Martha's Vineyard for our honeymoon,
which was an amazing, amazing place.
Well, in the commercial airline on the flight,
think about being 6'4", 400 pound man
in coach on a commercial flight, not fun, right?
You got to be embarrassed,
and ask the lady for a seatbelt extension,
and you are making everyone next to you uncomfortable.
My poor wife, she's got to sit,
and we lift up the armrest,
so I can spill over into her side, you know what I'm saying?
Did you have to buy two seats?
Did they make you buy two seats?
No, nobody ever made me buy two seats,
but we were strategic about where we would sit.
My wife is a lot smaller than I am so that helped a lot
that I was able to take up half of her seat.
Right.
But there was a Cessna flight
that I wasn't prepared for on that trip.
Oh, yeah,
'cause you got to take a little island hopper.
Right, I had no idea, I was not prepared for that.
(laughing)
She's laughing, she's still laughing at you.
You were fat when she married you.
Dude, yeah.
What does she think now?
She always says, she's always held,
'cause my wife, if you see our wedding pictures,
you'd go, what the hell was she thinking?
But she's ecstatic.
She said, she's always loved me no matter what,
which that feels really great to know.
And she's actually bought into the whole lifestyle with me.
She just did her speed work in the 40 degree, rain,
15 mile an hour wind that we're having down here right now.
So we're having a little mini competition
amongst ourselves right now, actually.
Oh, good, she sounds like, I think she's a keeper.
Oh yeah, definitely, keeper, she's a keeper.
And so, but yeah,
we're in this little Cessna and I have to actually
just kind of put one butt cheek in the seat,
and fold my leg up in the aisle behind me,
and the lady, the pilot, 'cause, I mean,
I'm basically sitting up on the pilot,
like, right behind her.
Well, actually, she moved me up to the front of the plane
because it's such a small plane
that she needed to shift the weight,
and it was very awkward,
and it was very, very embarrassing,
and very uncomfortable, very uncomfortable.
Yeah, I mean, I'm laughing
'cause it's all funny now, but like it's not funny.
I'm sure it wasn't funny at all at the time.
No.
This is a problem
that a lot of people have to deal with,
and it creates all that kind of shame,
and it makes you want to not engage with the world.
I mean, the trickle down effect of just the stuff
that you have to deal with on a daily basis,
and the amount of energy output that it requires
just to do something that would be simple.
To just do normal stuff that's right.
Exactly.
I was listening to an interview recently.
I can't remember where it was,
but it was this guy, Dave Asprey,
who he calls himself the Bulletproof Executive.
He's got a podcast.
It was on some podcast, but anyway,
he was talking about how a lot of people
who are really overweight have trouble losing weight
because everybody tells them that they need more willpower.
And what people don't realize
is that people that are tremendously overweight
are exerting more willpower on a daily basis
by far than the average human being,
because the amount of willpower it takes
just to sort of do the daily things,
you have a finite amount of willpower, right?
Right.
And it's expended on just that.
So to ask somebody to go above and beyond
to handle what seems like an obvious thing
for somebody who doesn't have to deal with that
is too much to bear.
Right, yeah, I get it.
Uh-huh, so, all right, so we're orbiting around
the 400, 410 area most likely, right?
That's right.
And so you're hitting the gym,
and you don't really have a plan.
You're just meeting your buddy at the gym,
and you guys are starting to turn things around.
So what are you doing?
You're just going to the treadmill?
Are you doing weights, or what's happening?
No, I'm not doing the treadmill at this point.
I'm just at the gym, going back to my old football roots,
lifting weights, that's what I'm doing.
Bench-pressing.
Bench-pressing, and doing bicep curls.
Uh-huh, you know, how come I'm not losing weight?
Yeah, right, and so I was.
Well, you were probably just by moving your body.
Right, just 'cause I was doing.
And one thing that I did change from the old workout was
I had increased my intensity 'cause at this point
I did understand that I didn't know what I needed to do.
And so I was actively seeking information
through this whole process.
And I was looking at places like "Men's Fitness" magazine,
and finding these, like, interval training,
and circuit training, so,
whereas, before I'd do three sets of 10,
and drink water in between the sets and all of these things,
now I was doing exercises,
and I was rotating through circuits and stuff.
So even though I wasn't doing cardio on the treadmill,
or running or anything like that,
I was lifting weights in a way
that was really more intense than I had ever done before.
Right.
So I was keeping myself sweating,
and, man, weight was just pouring off of me
in the beginning it was just pouring off.
But meanwhile, you hadn't really started
to take a look at your diet, right?
No.
So were you just going home,
and having the jambalaya, and the gumbo,
or, like, what are you eating at home?
Just doing less of it, quantities.
I was worried about my portion controls kind of a vibe.
That's what I was doing really.
And then on the weekends it was a complete free-for-all,
all the beer and whiskey and Po-Boys that I wanted.
It was like took the weekend off,
and work like a crazy man during the week,
and take the weekend off.
And I lost a lot of weight, too, while I was doing it,
but it's because I had so much to lose
that it came off kind of easy in the beginning.
Right, too loose, or to lose,
I thought you were giving me some weird Louisiana term,
or something, to lose, yeah.
Yeah, so you ended up dropping, like,
in a pretty short period of time.
I mean, you dropped, like, 60 pounds right away, right?
Just because you're moving yourself.
Right, I lose 60 pounds 'cause you got to remember
my main goal in the beginning was to look better in a suit
because I knew I was gonna have to don a suit,
and get in front of people who I already felt awkward around
because I'm 10 years older than everybody anyway, all right?
And on top of that I outweigh everybody about 200 pounds,
at least, so I'm trying to mitigate that as much as I can
during my senior year.
So when it comes time for my 490 business class,
and I made my big
coup de grâce presentation at the end
I don't look like a sweating fool up there
'cause I knew the material,
I knew what I was doing and I knew I could talk about it,
but I was scared to be distracted
by how bad I felt like I looked.
Right, and so by the time you graduate,
that was where you were 60 pounds down, right?
Right, that's correct.
So you're 320 and change, right, at that point?
That's right, that's right.
And then you sort of flip the page,
and a new chapter starts with this idea about
maybe trying to do a little running.
That's right, and it just clicked 'cause the gym
it's called Larousse's.
Uh-huh, it sounds like an Italian restaurant.
No, it's just a coon-ass name is Mr. Larousse,
but there's also a barber called Leroux Dan's,
that I almost said Leroux Dan's instead,
but, anyway, it's located on Tiger Drive,
which I went to Thibodaux High School,
which we were the Tigers,
and the Tiger Drive passes right in front of Thibodaux High,
and the gym is on Tiger Drive
right down the road from the high school.
And so I would pass down Tiger Drive,
and I would see this man who I've known very well.
My wife has known him all of her life.
I'd see him on the sidewalk doing this weird little,
like, I would laugh like a little jiggle,
and it was barely faster than a walk.
And I'm looking at him, and I was like,
hell, if Mr. Jeff can get it in I can do that, too,
so that's what I started doing, I just started.
I would just do that little jiggle and my buddy, Jeff,
the man that I modeled my initial running form after,
his name is Jeff as well,
but my workout buddy at this point, his name is Jeff.
So Jeff's would walk next to me
as I would do my little jog jiggle thing.
And that's how I started, man.
All right, you started with a jiggle.
That's it, dude.
You were just out jiggling.
At first it's kind of like a waddle, like a walk,
like more, like, brisk than a walk, but.
Right, and it was just kinda like,
it was more with the upper body,
like, it looked like I was doing more than I was, you know?
Right, and how far would you do that for?
A mile.
Uh-huh.
A mile, that's where I started.
And then after I would do the mile,
we did the mile after our weight routine every day.
Right.
And then I started
wanting to get faster in that mile, started wanting to go,
well, damn, it took us 15 minutes to do that, you know?
And then, so I started working my way down,
and I wanted to get it down below 10.
It took a long time and I was still in 12,
you know what I mean?
And one thing leads to the next and I was like,
I wanted to give myself a little shot in the arm,
something like a carrot on a stick, so to speak.
And that's when I told my buddy, Jeff, I was like,
hey, let's do the Crescent City Classic, man.
Let's sign up to do it right now,
and we're gonna work towards it.
That's like a 10K race.
That's a 10K, that's correct.
Right, right, right, right.
How far away was that?
Like how much time would you have to prepare?
It was a few months, huh?
Right.
It was a few months.
So you set a goal.
Yes, I set a goal.
Right, right.
I set a goal.
So what's the plan, like, just go further, faster?
Just build it up?
Yeah, just long miles, that was my thing.
I wanted to get distance.
I wasn't worried about how fast at that point.
My goal was to run the whole Crescent City Classic.
That's a pretty lofty goal
when you're just out there jiggling for a mile, right?
Yeah, it was, it was.
And in training and what caught me was this,
'cause we would do our training pre daylight hours
'cause we worked,
so we were at the gym at 4:30 in the morning,
and then we'd go run after.
So the furthest I ever got in my training,
quote, unquote, training for the 10K was four miles.
That was the longest non-stop run I had completed.
And that was just a week or so
before the Crescent City Classic.
Right, right.
So you're going into this you're not sure how it's gonna go.
Right, well, first of all,
the night before the Crescent City Classic,
we're in New Orleans having a good time.
We get a bottle of wine and a cheese plate at a place.
And some gouda beignets.
I don't even know what that is.
Well, it's a type of a cheese made into a beignet,
or beignets, that's right, fried cheese bread, basically.
Oh, I got you, okay.
Completely delicious,
and we drank a couple of bottles of wine.
This is pre-race, this is, like, night before the race.
(laughing)
So we get up and we go, and we're late for the start line.
We get there, I'm all excited, but we get there.
What I failed to realize in all of the training was
we had never run in the daylight.
Right.
And so we take off and we start running,
and not only am I just slightly hung over,
and I'm not really fueled up correctly.
We take off running and it was really taxing.
It was really, really taxing on me.
And I had to start walking in mile three.
Right, because of the heat,
the humidity and all that fried cheese in your belly.
And the night before, yeah.
Now I know that it was a terrible idea to do all that stuff.
I mean, it sounds like, duh, but really,
in my mind at the time I was like,
man, I'm about to go run six miles tomorrow.
I can have whatever I want.
That was literally the logic there, you know?
Right, all right, yeah, so you cramp up,
and you finish it, but you had to walk probably.
I wasn't proud of my effort at all.
Right.
I wasn't proud of what I had,
I was happy that we did the Crescent City Classic.
I did get through it,
but I wasn't really proud of what I had done.
Right, it took you,
like, just under two hours, right, to do it?
Yeah, the picture that I put on,
the before and after that you posted on your Facebook,
I ran that half marathon in 1:58:44.
Right.
So it's quite quite a difference.
Right, yeah, so at this time,
I mean, you're 320, right?
So you're down about 77 pounds.
That's right.
Right, but you got a little momentum, right?
I did 'cause of how that race went.
I was like, no, we gotta do better than this, you know?
And so
my wife started,
that's when my wife started getting onboard and she started,
she joined a gym here in town,
and she started doing her thing, too.
My brother saw me complete a 10K,
and that's when my brother wanted to get involved as well.
And all of these other people and it felt good that,
hey, we all can do it, we can do it.
Yeah, I mean, you're figuring out how to set goals.
Right.
You're creating community around what you're doing.
You have accountability to these people,
and you're making it fun
with the people that you care about.
I mean, that's like the recipe for success right there.
Right, and when I was listening to
Jeff Spencer the other morning,
and when he goes through those steps
that you were talking about with him,
and all of those things were just, like, going,
bling, bling, bling, in my head.
I was like, wow, I'm doing something right.
I feel like I could be on the path
of something really cool here.
And so, all right, so what's next then?
What's the next step here?
So the next step is my wife.
Once she gets involved, we set another lofty goal,
in my opinion,
at the time was to get it done in under an hour.
Yeah, you're gonna cut your time in half.
Cut it in half.
Right.
And you got a year to get ready for this, right?
Pretty much, yeah, yeah, got a year,
'cause we decide after that race that day,
that I'm doing it again and I'm gonna do it way better, so.
So you got this time to do it,
and around this time, too,
the other kind of thing that jumps out at me from your story
is this you're starting to reframe this idea
of what's possible,
and redefining the idea of impossible.
And I think that that is through the lens of this culture
that you live in where maybe it's not encouraged
to kind of step outside the norm and say,
I'm gonna do something
that's a little bit different from everybody else.
Right, right, especially with all of this
kind of hippie stuff that I'm partaking in these days.
Right, man, what's happening?
You're losing a thread, man.
Right, but there's a lot of folks that see it,
and go, maybe there's something to it.
I mean, we are,
Louisiana, Mississippi are bottom of the barrel
when it comes to health and it comes to obesity.
I mean, or top of the class, however you want to frame it
when it comes to very negative things, you know?
I think it's time to adopt a new normal here.
Right, I mean, when this is happening,
are your friends giving you shit,
or are they giving you a pat on the back?
I mean, what's the reaction?
You've lost a bunch of weight,
but you're hardly the way you look now.
No, absolutely.
And everybody was pumped for me when I was,
they were more happy.
They were very happy that I was losing the weight,
and that I was looking good.
That's the constant compliment is,
oh, man, you look so amazing.
You look good, you're losing some weight, and all of that,
but, yeah, everybody was really happy for me,
and really pumped about the running thing, you know?
Right, so you're getting encouragement, all right.
And now you're gonna get ready
to try to cut your time in half.
So where does the kind of
new look at food start to creep into the equation?
That happened right around the time
I had started preparing for that part.
It didn't fully happen.
My new look at running itself happened in my training
for that second Crescent City Classic.
The food epiphany came after.
Oh, I see, all right.
So we got another year of you
just progressively learning how to run.
Right, and I'm looking for role models
in that activity, and that's when I read,
I read "Born to Run" at that time,
and I was like blown away at how people run 50 miles,
people run hundreds of miles.
I mean, this was like crazy it blew my mind.
And I was like, and here I am, I'm okay.
So 10 miles is not that big of a deal.
And so I basically just kept doing exactly
what I had been doing all along with maybe more salads,
and less Po-Boys,
but still plenty of beer, whiskey and Po-Boys along the way.
I think a lot of it was just me getting lighter,
and that next year helped me really shave that time down,
I mean.
And having my wife who was actually outrunning me
the whole time,
chasing her down really kept us on pace,
and that's how we got below the hour.
Right, so you did,
you finished it in 59 minutes, right?
59 minutes.
So you achieved that goal.
Yes, it was very close.
My little marathon photo things that you get after races
that you go online and you get every one of them,
my action photos, like the one that you see now,
but every one of those photos for that race,
looks like I'm about to die.
(laughing)
I mean, 'cause I'm like, this is I'm redlining it
because I want to make this goal, you know.
So I get it done and I'm like, cool, got it done,
that was pretty taxing,
but after that race,
we go to one of my favorite Po-Boy places.
We (indistinct)
Right.
So we go to one of my favorite Po-Boy places,
and I have a beer and an oyster Po-Boy,
and we have some chili cheese fries,
and a Barq's root beer.
So there's people that listen to the show
that live in different countries and all that kind of stuff.
No, I just want you to tell people what a Po-Boy is,
who may not know.
A Po-Boy is a sandwich made on a French loaf,
all right?
Very chewy French bread,
and tons of mayo, lettuce, tomatoes, pickles,
and fried oysters is my favorite.
That's what I used to always get, so it's a sandwich,
and it's a loaf, an entire loaf of bread, basically,
that's split longways.
And then you slather it with mayo,
and you put shredded lettuce, tomatoes, pickles,
and you have your meat of choice,
and mine was always fried oysters was what I would get.
And so here we are post race after this enormous exertion.
And that's what I've put in my body immediately after.
And we really felt like crap after we ate all of that
'cause I had read "Born to Run"
I knew what I probably should be doing,
and what other successful runners were doing.
And I did that.
But it's also natural to just go out,
and celebrate, too.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So at this point you lost 120 pounds.
Right.
So you're tipping out at 285,
something like that, right?
Right in that neighborhood, that's right.
Right.
That's where I was.
But you kind of normalized there, right?
Like it had stabilized.
I did 'cause we were getting close to Mardi Gras
at that point, all right?
And so what happened after that race, okay?
Me and my wife both, yeah,
I might have the timeline a little mixed up.
I think Mardi Gras comes before that,
but, anyway, what happens is we wind up,
adopt, cause I felt really guilty after that meal.
And I felt really bad physically after that meal,
and my wife winds up reading about eating clean,
and that's when the food thing started to change.
I didn't really want to do that.
I really wanted to just keep doing physical exertion
of physical exercise.
Right.
And just eat less of the bad stuff,
but still have it as part of my.
Yeah, you're still holding on.
Right, that's exactly right.
Yeah, and you're thinking if I just keep running
I can get faster every year,
the weight's still going to come off.
Right.
All that kind of stuff.
But that starting to slow down.
Right, so you were pretty much plateaued at 285.
I was plateaued and then deep down in my heart,
and in the back of my head,
I knew I had done that before.
I hadn't lost quite that much weight before,
but I knew I had lost a lot of weight before,
and once it started to slow down, I could see it.
I could really see it start to go back.
I could see, I could imagine it coming all right back.
So in the past when you dropped a ton of weight,
and then regained it, I mean,
what were you doing to lose it and why did you regain it?
Well, I would pick a goal weight.
So I would say I want to get down to 250,
and then so that's what I would do.
Like, I don't know if you've ever heard of Jon Gabriel,
but he talks a lot about being able to
get weight off of your body through sheer force,
how that's totally possible, and that's what I would do.
I would just work really hard and eat a little less,
and make the weight come off,
and I would get to that goal weight,
and then I would celebrate with Po-Boys and beer,
and have a good time.
I know.
And then slowly float right back up to where I was,
and all the time, I mean, that's exactly.
It's the normal thing because all the emphasis,
and all the focus is on hitting that number.
And once you've hit that number, you've achieved your goal.
You take your foot off the gas
because you're not changing your lifestyle.
You're not creating a new sustainable lifestyle
that you're gonna be able to live with over time.
Yeah, and that's exactly what happened.
The eating clean thing, even though it still included me,
eating clean made me feel a lot better.
No processed food,
and it really made me feel a lot better.
At that point
is when I saw the documentary, "Fat, Sick, and Nearly Dead."
It was while we were eating clean.
Right, right.
And I was like, holy cow, this guy did this,
and with the trucker, the guy Phil in that thing,
I'm like it just was it blew me away, you know?
Right, right.
And the way he broke it down
with the little cartoons about your body,
all the processes in your body needing clean fuel,
and all that, it all made sense, you know?
So this has you thinking about
maybe doing something completely insane.
Right.
- I actually did try the juice thing, okay?
And it didn't do, my wife is laughing.
How many days did you make it?
I made it three days.
Three's not bad.
I made it three days and I thought I was gonna die.
(laughing)
I felt like I had the worst flu on the planet.
In retrospect, I went from eating way too unclean
to going to that far.
Yeah, that's pretty extreme.
I made too big of a leap.
Right.
But it did make me go,
it did make me rethink the meat thing.
And that's when I was like, what's another clean,
and it's just a progression that happened
'cause after that is when I saw "Forks Over Knives."
And then I saw "Forks Over Knives."
And then I saw "Hungry for Change,"
and I saw "Food Matters,"
which Netflix, I have to give a huge shout-out to
for helping me along this process.
It's been invaluable to me,
but yeah, and after watching all of those things,
and hearing all those guys spew forth about
need to give up animal products,
need to give up meat and dairy and all these things.
After I heard it for about the fifth or sixth time,
I was like, okay, let me try.
And that's when I brought it up to my brother,
I said, I'm doing it
because I was also telling my brother about
all of these things along the way.
A lot of these people seemed like they might contradict
one another a little bit.
It's not necessarily 100% consistent message
all the way through,
so you got to take what you hear with a grain of salt.
So when I tell him that I'm gonna go completely plant-based
he's like, "What happened to that grain of salt, bro?"
I said, just give me a chance and let me try it.
And then let's see, and the rest is history after that.
I mean, were they just looking at you
rolling their eyes, going he's completely lost his mind.
People are still rolling their eyes at me,
and crinkling up their face when they go, what did you do?
And then I tell them, and then they go,
uh, I just can't do that.
Well, no, you can, you just probably won't.
Right, but you had this willingness to try this.
I mean, did you set an expectation for it,
or you just went into it completely open,
like, let's just see what happens?
Completely open, I went in.
I knew that I didn't want to go back,
like I'd always done before in my life.
And I knew it was time for something that was gonna be real.
And I knew I needed a way of living and eating
that was gonna be sustainable for me 'cause I still,
I like to eat a pretty good volume of food.
That's comfortable to me, that feels good.
I like to eat food.
I don't like to feel like I'm starving.
That was the biggest thing for me was understanding that,
oh, I can eat, man.
Right, what do you think, I mean,
why didn't you say,
well, I'm gonna just start eating maybe more plants?
What was it about where you were at
that you were ready to just turn the volume up to 10,
and just do it 100%?
Because I think a lot of people struggle with that idea.
They're like, yeah, I should eat more vegetables,
and whatever,
but I'm not ready to completely let go of the other stuff.
Like they want to keep their little toe
still on the other side of that line.
Right, well, for me what it was,
was I had started really to fall in love with running.
And so I was reading about folks like you,
and Brendan Brazier, reading y'all's books,
and Scott Jurek, and every one of y'all
was the exact same message over and over and over.
And I was like,
okay, maybe I'm not aiming to be an ultra marathoner,
but if I do want to do this,
and be a runner,
like the runners I see running around New Orleans,
going up and down Saint Charles Avenue,
and around City Park and around Audubon Park.
If I want to be one of those guys,
I feel like this is what I need to do.
And that's really what helped me along with going
completely plant-based
was understanding that if I want to be a runner,
this can really, really help, and is optimal fuel for it.
I mean, I think the proof is in the pudding so to speak.
Yeah, well, it definitely is now.
I mean, did you set, like,
I'm gonna do it for 30 days and evaluate,
or just I'm doing this?
I said 30 days,
but I really kind of felt like I was gonna wind up
sticking to it very shortly after I started
because the clean thing had started working.
The clean eating felt so good for me.
And then that was just a matter of
removing the chicken breasts
'cause that's really all I was eating
was chicken breasts and fish.
Were you eating that fried cheese still?
No, the fried cheese is a thing of the past.
All right, so you jump into this.
I mean, how did it go, like, the first week?
I had no qualms with it whatsoever.
I really didn't.
So it just agreed with you from the beginning?
It agreed with me from the beginning, I loved it.
The only issue that I had was trying to figure out
how to really like kale in the beginning,
'cause I had read so much about kale and all these things.
I was struggling with kale a little bit.
And what about getting, you're still 285,
you like to eat a lot, like what about volume,
or making sure that you feel full at the end of a meal,
stuff like that?
That's how me and kale got to be friends
because I could eat a bucket full of kale.
I would made this little dressing.
Right, well, before Chef AJ,
'cause my wife's telling me Chef AJ's dressing
really helped me out with kale,
which it absolutely did it.
but before that I was doing my own little thing
with some spaghetti sauce and stuff
like out of some organic stuff from the jar,
which I don't even eat.
Putting spaghetti sauce on kale salad?
Yeah, I was putting spaghetti sauce on kale,
mashing it all up, but the kale,
I felt like it held its shape better down in my stomach
when I understood what stretch receptors do,
and stuff like that.
So I knew that I needed to get my stomach
to be able to be satisfied I needed to fill up my stomach.
And so kale, I felt like did that in a better way
than say some other softer lettuce would have done.
Right.
And that, so that's how I would get
my volume of food that I wanted.
That's where it started, you know?
Mm-hmm, and, I mean,
what were the kind of initial noticeable differences
that you started to feel?
My clarity of mind,
and how energetic I was.
I didn't have any issues getting up 'cause like I said,
we're early morning gym people we still are to this day,
very early gym people.
That was just I was up and bright-eyed, bushy-tailed.
I was ready to rock and roll.
I stayed sore for a shorter period of time
after giving workouts, after runs.
Right, recovering more quickly.
I felt lighter on my feet during my runs.
As I started to adopt better form,
it was easier 'cause I felt more springy.
I just felt amazing.
And the biggest one, though, for me was lighter,
and not in a sense of not being a big fat guy anymore,
but lighter in my gut.
Like my body is getting rid of all of this unused food,
and it's not sitting in there.
And so there's this natural cycle
that's supposed to be happening that's happening.
And that regularity,
I know we talk about weird stuff now that we eat plants,
but that regularity is a big part of my life.
I love it, I feel amazing.
It just slides right out.
It's amazing, dude, it's crazy.
And the other thing that I love about your story
at this moment in time when you made this switch,
that coincided with that moment where you decided
forget about the scale, like, it's not about the number.
I'm not doing this to lose weight.
I'm doing this because I want to be a runner
because I want to be fit and healthy,
so you shifted that mindset
away from that kind of temporary goal
that had you rubber banding in terms of your weight,
and focused on changing your lifestyle.
And I think that's the key,
and I think that's why you've been able to maintain it.
Right, and I feel like,
and everyone has their own opinion,
but from what I've read,
and my experience with this whole thing, I feel like we're,
obviously, basically, just animals here on the planet Earth.
We happen to be fancy animals,
but I feel like we were like, McDougall's book.
We really were born to run.
That's what we've evolved to do.
And I feel like we've evolved to eat plants and run,
those two basic things.
And if you want to be the most natural human form
that has sprung forth from this earth to do whatever,
but if you want to get in touch
with that natural human essence of that being
that you're supposed to be,
I feel like running and plants is where it's at.
That's what I've adopted along the way.
And it has really changed my outlook on everything.
That's beautifully put,
and you're officially a hippie now.
Yeah, I know, that's weird.
I mean, beyond the kind of off the plate,
beyond the food conversation,
this process of learning how to run,
and learning to get better at it,
and really embracing the joy that comes along with that,
I mean, how else has that affected your life
in terms of just this sort of
changes, personal changes that kind of occur
when you spend so much time with yourself, like out running.
I mean, I know the answer for myself,
but I'm interested in, you know.
Well, I spent a lot of time.
I used to do a whole lot of running
with ear buds with music blaring in there.
And I still do from time to time.
Depends on how long of a run I'm on, and all,
but most of the time,
'cause now I'm running 13, 14 mile runs,
whereas, before I'd run a lot less,
I spent a lot less time out there.
It's almost like a meditation kind of for me.
I've been studying,
I've been reading up on meditation here lately.
That's kind of like my next phase in the metamorphosis.
I feel like it's a natural progression for me
is I've been real interested in meditation,
and maybe even moving towards yoga some,
but I practice my breathing while I'm on my runs,
and I find a lot of parallels between my run breathing,
and the meditation breathing
that I've read about a little bit.
And it helps me think about some really deep things.
I really just get a real peace when I'm all by myself,
and it's me and my breath and my foot falls in the scenery,
whether it's in New Orleans, or here on the Bayou,
I really feel like I'm deeply connected to the natural human
that I've evolved to be.
That's beautiful, I love that.
And I want to share that with my folks
that
think that sounds crazy.
So what is it like when,
I would imagine now, I mean, sort of fast-forwarding to now,
well, the other sort of step that we missed
is that once you made the switch,
then you sort of broke through the glass ceiling
on your weight, and it started dropping off you like crazy.
Right.
And ultimately you get down,
like, what did you get down to?
Well, right now I weigh 203.
Okay, 203.
So you literally lost half your body weight.
Yeah.
Right, and when you look at
that before and after picture, I mean,
it's hard to even fathom that that is the same guy.
You look like a completely different person.
Right, and this isn't the same guy at all.
Right, and you live in a small community
where people know you and what is that like when people,
I would imagine that there is this sort of
cultural resistance that you experience,
or you butt up against, but at the same time,
especially given kind of the extent to which obesity,
and diabetes and things like that
are a problem down where you live,
that in a sort of private moment,
that friend who's given you shit at the party
is the same guy who is coming up to you and saying,
hey, man, like, what are you doing?
'Cause they have to experience the same thing
that you're experiencing when you're on the plane,
or all those kind of small little things on a daily basis
that affect their lives,
deteriorate the quality of their lives.
So I would imagine that maybe people are more interested,
and more curious than they let on initially.
Yeah, you're right.
And the more I beat my drum,
the more I start to see people
kind of tap their foot a little bit to use an analogy.
I mean, 'cause I'm beating my drum, dude,
because I love these folks down here.
I love where I'm from.
I love the culture I was raised in.
I'm just trying to be an example that people can follow,
and say, God-Dawg, Josh LaJaunie did that?
'Cause everybody knows me.
They know where I was, you know?
And if I can do it, man, anybody can do it,
but, yes, there are folks.
'Cause I have people my age, literally.
I'm a young man still,
and I got people my age that's on statin drugs,
had a heart attack last year in the gym
trying to lose weight,
but not really doing the whole package.
I'm talking about one guy I'm not gonna call him out,
but it just blows my mind that I have folks my age
that are dealing with this,
what used to be an old man problem,
but to answer your question about
are people that are giving me shit
kind of maybe turning the corner?
Absolutely, absolutely, I see it every day, but I make sure,
I don't pull punches like I used to,
by sort of appeasing the people that I'm around.
When people ask me, I tell them.
I don't bring it to you, but if you got a question for me,
you open the gate and I'll go with it, you know?
And then you tell them you just eat plants,
and then they.
And they they, like, they crinkle up their face,
and then they're like, well, what about drinking?
Oh, you don't drink anymore either?
And I'm like, I may have a glass of wine.
Maybe once I can't even say it's not even enough regularity,
and say I can't even tell you the last time I've had,
I'm not interested.
It doesn't even appeal to me to have.
I'm cool, but I don't miss it either, you know?
But that one's the big one for them.
The drinking 'cause the drinking is a pretty big thing,
that's kind of what we do.
Right.
But it's okay to not,
and that's where I want to try to be a beacon for.
Hey, it's okay that that's what we've always done.
It's okay to not do what we've always done.
It's okay.
It's okay, the world's not gonna crumble, man.
And that's it, I mean.
I'm just trying to,
you know, be an example.
Well, I mean, the thing is
you don't have to tell anybody.
I mean, first of all, you shouldn't tell anyone what to do,
but you don't have to because your personal transformation
is so dramatic and you're not an outsider.
You're one of them, they all know you.
Yep.
And all you have to do is share your experience,
you know?
This is what happened to me.
You want to know what happened to me?
This is what happened.
And then they're gonna do with that
what they're gonna do with it,
but that's not your business really, you know?
That's exactly right, all I can do is do that.
My grandmother used to have this little saying
hanging up in the offices that said,
actions speak louder than words.
So sit down and shut up,
but actions do speak louder than words.
I feel like I'm trying to scream at the top of the lungs
with my actions,
without preaching to people with actual words.
I think that
I like doing that, I like it.
You're in a position to help a lot of people,
and a lot of people that need help.
I think you're ready to do that,
and to serve your community.
I mean, I could see you being like Phil
in "Fat, Sick, and Nearly Dead"
holding those little, like, workshops in the market,
and showing people how to strip the kale.
I mean,
you are perfectly situated to start your own little
plant powered revolution down there, man.
And that's what I want.
That's really, you know, I really want that.
I really do, and I really want,
and I've done it in my immediate family.
I've been able to be the impetus for some change
among some people that I love very, very dearly.
And that makes me immensely proud.
And I tell my mom all the time because,
and I hadn't even mentioned my mom
who just ran a 5K a couple of weeks.
Oh, wow.
My mom who was,
you know how ladies are with weight,
I can't say weight,
but my mom has lost significant weight.
And she's been a person that's had,
she had scoliosis when she was little,
and she's got an 18 inch rod in her back.
And so that's always that built-in excuses
to why we can't do something, and she's overcome that.
She's overcome that in recent months,
and I'm just crazy proud of what she's been able to do.
My brother is blowing stuff out the water
with his running and his weight loss.
My wife is killing it.
My little sister is killing it.
Even my 80-year-old grandpa who can't move very much,
he's sitting at the house, but just through osmosis,
he's got to eat plants, too, 'cause everybody else is,
and he's losing weight as well.
That's amazing.
And so I want it to spread, man.
And I get the idea,
something that you talk about a lot, too,
is this idea of transitional foods,
and for people that aren't ready for the kale salad yet
to introduce to them something that can be delicious,
regardless of whether you're a vegan, or whatever you are.
Those things I think are very, very powerful.
Even though you can't maybe make a complete diet
of said transitional foods,
they are very powerful to just introduce
into people's brains that eating plants don't have to suck.
Yeah, and then you gotta meet people
where they're at, you know?
That's right, man, that's right.
Yeah, I mean, it's huge.
I mean, you are permanently changing these people's lives.
It's amazing.
I mean, the other thing that people ask me all the time is,
oh, well, it's easy for you, you live in Los Angeles.
It's like Whole Foods on every corner,
and every restaurant has vegan options,
and all that kind of stuff,
but I mean you live, I mean, I can't imagine
many places in the United States
where it would be more challenging to kind of shop,
and get the kind of foods that you need.
So how does that work down there?
Dude, every grocery store
has got a produce department.
There you go.
I've never been at a grocery store
without a produce department.
And so when all else fails,
hit the produce department, man.
We're lucky in Thibodaux
because we have a home-grown business called Rouses,
and they do supermarkets, all right?
And they are very receptive to what you ask for.
So if you go and you say,
Hey, look, I would really like some Uncle Sam's oat bran.
They'll make sure that it's on the shelf for you.
I love the fact that you have almond milk,
and I know y'all don't do boxed almond milk,
but I still do the almond milk,
it's just easier for me,
but, anyway, I get the unsweetened almond milk,
and it's amazing to see since I've started doing this,
how much more of these items
are being stocked in the grocery store,
because I see it happening.
I see more people getting Ezekiel bread.
I see more people getting almond milk.
I see more people getting raw almond butter, and quinoa.
We have quinoa in bins
just like they have in Whole Foods now at the Rouses.
And it's really cool to see all of this happening, you know?
That's crazy.
Well, I mean, I would imagine this is you, man.
I mean, who else is going in there,
and requesting that stuff?
Well, my family, yeah, we're doing it as a whole.
My mom was the one
that asked the manager for stuff at Rouses.
I never have personally asked the manager
to get that for me at Rouses, but I know mama well,
and I know that's probably where these things
that that stuff's coming from.
And what about, like, how do you handle it
when you have to go to a restaurant?
I do like you, man, I pre-eat, bro.
That's what I do, I pre-eat in an event
that my only option is gonna be a dressingless salad.
Right.
So that way we don't have to go to some
off the wall place just 'cause Josh is a vegan,
or Josh and B.J., my wife as well,
she eats the same way, so,
but I don't need to be difficult.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's a big stumbling block
for a lot of people or just a fear.
So they have this fear, like, if I do this,
then I'm gonna be that guy who's always a pain in the butt,
and so they just don't even want to try,
because they're projecting into the future
some circumstance, or situation,
that's gonna be tricky to navigate.
I get me a big old bowl of raw oats
with some almond milk and some grapes,
and I'll fill up my stomach and I'm full,
and then we go to a restaurant.
Right.
And then that way,
if they do have something there I'll be satisfied,
and if they don't,
I can get a few leaves on a plate and I'm still satisfied.
Right, or maybe a baked potato or something, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and it's funny when I order
I like San Pellegrino,
and people look at me crooked
because I'm Josh from Thibodaux,
and I'm drinking San Pellegrino with a lime please.
And it's kind of funny, but it's good, I like it, it's cool.
It's fun if you want to make it fun.
It can suck if you want to be that way, too.
It's your perspective on it.
That's it, and whether you think you can,
or you think you can't, you're right either way.
That's the truth.
And that's just it, you know?
And my wife and I both have a love for not only here,
but that beautiful gem of a city that we have here
in this state called New Orleans.
We're only 60 miles from it,
and we have season tickets for the New Orleans Saints,
and we are massive, massive New Orleans Saints fans.
And one of the biggest things that I mentioned in there
that really sort of shook my world
when it comes to possible and impossible
was the fact that we were able to win a Super Bowl,
which
it's settled in, but at the time it was that blew my mind.
That will get you to rethink what's possible,
and impossible, right?
Correct, the Saints won the Super Bowl.
It's like, yeah.
If that's possible, anything, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so Sean Payton
is like a big part of your story, right?
Yeah, Sean Payton is amazing.
For people out of the country tell us who he is.
Sean Payton is the head coach
for the New Orleans Saints.
It's an NFL football team here in America.
NFL football here in New Orleans.
And so what happened is
we've been the laughing stock
for the most part of our NFL existence.
We've had some little spurts of good things that happened.
Those spurts also happened to coincide
with the San Francisco 49ers in NFC West,
which is our division
having their dynasty at the same time
that we tried to raise our little heads.
And we never really accomplished anything
with our little bit of winning that we did
in the late '80s, early '90s.
However, for the most part of our existence,
we've been just the laughing stock.
And what happens is we get Sean Payton
after the devastation of Hurricane Katrina down here,
basically, we win the Super Bowl.
It's like a crazy Cinderella story.
Amazing, we get Drew Brees
to come over from San Diego
who shattered his throwing shoulder,
and we pick him up, and he just is,
I mean, I really think he's on the way to being arguably,
one of the greatest,
if not the greatest quarterback of all time.
And Sean Payton is doing the same thing
in the realm of head coach.
Those things are really sorta
stretch what you believe is possible.
And after the Super Bowl victory,
I was still very heavy at the time
right after the Super Bowl.
I read Sean Payton's book,
and he talked a lot about those,
he used a lot of F-words in his book and I loved it,
and he kept me reading, you know, but I loved it.
And he talked a lot about forget about what normal is,
and screw that's the way it always is down here,
that sort of vibe,
and just basically reach outside the box,
and adopt a new normal, and that really resonated with me.
And I was like, okay, coach, that's what we need to do, man.
Yeah, break the paradigm.
That's it, bro.
You know, I mean,
some places are more open-minded than others,
but I think that from the way you describe it,
where you live they're not so open to new ideas.
Right, and my thing I think
that we can see as a roadblock is our culinary prowess here,
especially in the city of New Orleans.
I mean, it's a global draw to go to some of the restaurants
in the French Quarter and uptown,
and just around the city of New Orleans it's a global draw.
When you start talking about wanting to eat healthy,
and wanting to be plant-based,
that becomes a roadblock in people's minds,
but so much of our economy
is tied into this food that we sell.
I think you can flip all that on its head and say,
we actually have some of the most capable
culinary talent in the world right here in this city.
And if anybody can turn eating plants
into something desirable, it's us.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I mean, not only did you overcome this tremendous amount
of weight that you were carrying around,
you had to do it in a community that wasn't exactly
supportive initially,
and you had to do it in the midst of incredible temptation
by some of the tastiest food on the planet.
I mean, the food in New Orleans is insane, right?
So, I mean, how do you deal with cravings?
Like, I think that's another thing that a lot of people
really struggle with.
I don't really crave much anymore.
I crave, you know,
my big sins nowadays are too much nut butter,
or too many hands full of raw cashews,
but as far as me craving 'cause of where I came from,
and what I'm doing now and where I'm headed,
honestly, honestly from the bottom of my heart,
I don't crave and understanding that pleasure trap concept.
I know you've heard about it.
And I know a lot of people listening have heard about
that pleasure trap and what that is.
Right, it's Doug Lisle's idea, right.
And understanding
that when I walk past a barbecue joint,
and bells and whistles go off in my head,
because of the smells that I'm experiencing,
understanding why that's happening has really sort of
really quieted down any cravings I might have.
It really has helped a tremendous amount.
And plus being able to identify foods
like some of the smoothies that I enjoy
as like these things are just like,
so out of this world delicious
that I crave those now, you know what I mean?
Right.
And you can't make an entire diet
of fruit smoothies, but that is a good one.
It's a good transition for somebody
to get into plant-based living.
And, two, it's a good place for people
who are in the plant-based lifestyle to have something
that really lights up all those bells and whistles,
you know?
Right, right.
I mean, do you have people that say to you now,
hey, listen, you look great.
You lost all this weight.
Like, now what's wrong with having a Po-Boy once in a while?
Well,
I know exactly what I tell those people,
I say, me and Po-Boy we're not talking.
(laughing)
And that's just it.
Me and Po-Boy we fell out, bro.
There's no love lost between me and Po-Boy.
Right, all right, man.
And just look at my before pictures, man.
Yeah.
And I know how I felt on the inside,
and I know what it did to me,
and even my brain and my way of thought.
Me and Po-Boy we just don't get along anymore.
All right, I hear you, man.
All right, well, let's wrap it up here,
but before we go, I wanted to ask you,
like, if there's anything you want to sort of
let people know before we tune out here,
or like some words of inspiration,
or just something that people might not understand,
or fully realize or appreciate about
adopting this new lifestyle that you have
because a lot of people listen to show it's not all vegans.
There's all different kinds of people, so.
People are curious, though,
and what might they not really understand
that you want to make sure you get across?
The biggest misconception I think is
it doesn't
suck to eat only plants.
I see that face that people make all the time.
It is amazing what your body,
your mind and your soul can do when you get in touch
with what we're supposed to be doing naturally.
And I think plants and running is exactly where it's at,
you know?
Right on, man, I love it.
All right, well, big love to you, man.
I appreciate it.
Keep doing what you're doing,
and you know it would be awesome,
is if you check in with me once in a while,
let me know how it's going down there.
Like, I want to see you catalyze this movement.
Oh, you got it, man.
I got some stuff in the works, too.
Me and my wife are working on some things
there in the city that
we look forward to sharing with folks.
Excellent, man.
And what's next for you?
You got a marathon you're getting ready for, right?
Yeah, I've got a marathon I'm gonna do, I think,
my big goal was the Rock 'n' Roll Marathon,
Rock 'n' Roll New Orleans,
but I've talked to a few people,
actually, since you re-posted my picture
a whole bunch of people have been blowing me up, so.
I have a few people that want me to go do
the Louisiana Marathon, which is in Baton Rouge.
And it's gonna be a month before the Rock 'n' Roll,
which I'm thinking about doing that as a prelude
to the Rock 'n' Roll Marathon.
Oh, cool.
Because there's gonna be a vegan village
at that Louisiana Marathon post run,
which is a pet peeve of mine.
We never have good healthy food at the event to eat
after a race.
It's always like, hey, all right,
here's the beer and the pizza and the fried shit,
and the jambalaya.
I'm like where's the good stuff that we need right now?
Our body is starving for nutrition at this point,
at this moment in particular.
And so the fact that they're gonna have that
at the Louisiana Marathon really has me excited.
And I think I'm gonna participate just for that fact alone.
That's cool.
The Louisiana Marathon might cut in front
of my Rock 'n' Roll Marathon.
Gotcha.
Yeah, just so you know, I mean,
I think I emailed this to you,
but when I posted that picture,
that before and after picture on my Facebook page,
that got the most sort of views or likes, or whatever
of anything I've ever posted on my Facebook page ever.
That's crazy.
Like it just blew it up like crazy.
People were re-posting it and sharing it all over the place.
Like I looked at the numbers, I was like, holy smokes.
That was the most popular thing I've ever posted on my page.
I literally sat in my truck looking at my iPhone,
tingling, nervous, didn't know how to take it.
Like, 'cause my Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
was going bananas and I was just like really?
It's just me, you know, really?
And so, yeah, that was a really cool moment.
And I don't know how to thank you enough for that.
That was just really, really awesome.
Thank you for doing what you're doing.
And your story is incredible,
and you are an inspiration you really are.
And I really hope that you embrace that,
and really understand the power of your story,
and the impact that you can have,
not just on your community, but everywhere you go.
I'm trying.
All right, man, you're doing it.
Thank you, Rich.
So if people want to check you out,
you're on Twitter, what's your Twitter?
It's my name, which is Josh LaJaunie,
which is I'll spell the last name.
Everybody knows how to spell it.
My last name is LaJaunie, L-A-J-A-U-N-I-E.
And I'm @joshlajaunie on Twitter, same thing on Instagram.
And you can hook up with me on Facebook as well, man.
Right on, and I'm gonna post
those before and after pictures
on the page where I'm posting this episode.
I think I'm gonna your manifesto, man, Free Josh LaJaunie.
Can I post that on my website?
Sure, buddy.
Is that cool?
Sure, I started a blog.
Oh, you got a blog, cool, what's the blog?
Come on, man, I'm trying to promote your stuff.
Josh LaJaunie at wordpress.com.
It's basically the same little thing that I sent you
because I just want to share it with more people
all at one time, you know?
Right, right.
And I'll repost the link to that on Facebook,
and Twitter and all for people to be able to get to it
if people want to read more about it,
but I plan on doing some more posts on the blog.
I have a lot more to say,
and we have a lot more in store.
This is just the beginning, man.
Yeah, I got no doubt, man.
All right, man, well, peace with you.
All right.
Thanks so much for taking the time, dude.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
And they love your wife B.J., too.
Is she gonna run the marathon with you?
You damn skippy.
All right, good.
All right, buddy, peace, plants.
(soft music)